The cognitive benefits of speaking a second language have been touted for years.
But many monolingual adults think that their moment has passed.
A new study in the analysis of neurology says it's not the case.
Researchers studied 853 people who took an intelligence test in 1947 at age 11...
...and then were tested again recently in their 70s.
They found that bilingual speakers perform much better than expected...
...on the later cognitive tasks given their scores on the 1947 test,...
...and people who spoke three languages performed even better.
That was true no matter their IQs...
...or if the speakers had learned the languages before or after they were 18.
Researchers concluded that learning an additional language...
...may have brain benefits comparable to physical fitness and not smoking.